нагадай вона прийдуть не випуск школи кгб
народний депутат breeder качу про людну
плювання означає розмолом ватра порошенка
джо байден і шляхи нам м година він блогер
андре луганської забарвлення такса схожу
програмою запасів розмова не побуту
зарінського з путіним давайте підійдемо з
повні записи розмов
що свідчать міжнародні
корупції та зовнішньому управлінні України я
Володимир зеленський
я фабрику та плівки тому що мені
страшно не сниться порошенко та його порах
роботи вони називають мене поганими словами
відправляють ростів Володимир Володимирович
забери мене звідси мені здається Петро
порошенко може стати наступним
президентом
вороги та друзі та передплатники андрей
бугайський дякує вам за всі лайки і
перегляди
найближчим часом чекайте нового придатного
контенту дякую що ви з нами
[музика]
[оплески]
я про панду вчить це наша розмова андрей
луганського блага розра що автора
rummikub андрею добрий вечір добрий
підвищив його нас я вам хочу сказати
водитися з нікітину за те серйозне
три рази вакууму почули газ повторювати
метро [ __ ] не шодому людина волосся і
путін і ксенії собчак і пізно розрив ти
ну і без посередників колоб лівак виходить
шукається розмиваючи кого прилюдний раптом аж
на пройдуть не фейк я це відео зробив на
колінці за всім за 8 хвилин дешевий
стандартний домашній комп'ютер і б
програма і все тобто програма
мінімальний відеомонтаж мінімальний на
стандартному шо вам комп'ютери все ну що
а якщо використовувати нейромережі, а якщо
використовувати можливості якщо
використовувати технічні можливості
які є у кгб але можна зробити все
що завгодно сьогодні століття технологій можна
зробити ще й відео за допомогою нервів
мереж ви бачили все відео в twitter і в
фейсбуці коли підставляються особи зірок
наприклад знамениті кадри з якихось
відео зі старих фільмів на цьому
термінатор 2 замість шварценеггера можна
підставити я не знаю зеленого і він
буде говорити голосом мешканець когось і
виглядати як зелений це буде
нормальний практично ви не побачите
ніякої різниці є цілий такий ось
сфера розваги людей які
займаються монтажем
що це довіряти ні не варто таким
плівкам довіряти не варто таке можна
змонтувати, а якби я витратив 3 дні
якби вичистив звук якби трошки
ми склеїли ось так як було б правильніше
ну ось щоб не було чути, що це
зроблено незграбно його ось так але знову ж
якщо послухати ці плівки кучеря я і
був на попередній прес-конференції я
все це чув сам там же навіть чутно
ось ця монтажна склеювання чути туди
тут шелест коли 11 клас
але коли ось блогер коли люблять це
робить відеомонтаж та працює зі звуком
а сьогодні це роблять практично всі вже
в цей
доступно на телефоні це можна зробити
на телефоні ви чуєте у момент склеювання
коли таке ну шелест різниця в звуку
голосніше тут трохи тихіше клас класу це
чути на плитках деркача так званої
які плівки немає ні сьогодні жодних
плівка фізично плівка це раніше була
газета що викрутили пам'ятайте на
олівці техніки клинок не все записано
на цифрові носії або це
телефон або якісь диктофон вони всі
цифрові
обробка їх дуже просто елементарно
цьому варто довіряти ні не варто
потрібно проводити експертизи потрібно
показувати джерела де взяв плівки
деркач хто їх монтував де сам
джерело але це абсолютно недоказово
абсолютно тому що але це все нісенітниця
і сьогодні вже соцмережі та twitter та
фейсбук сповнені цих роликів де люди
підставляють їсти спеціальна програма
її можна скачати собі встановити на
телефон зовсім як називається
програма я, програма називається як
програма називається
пародист вона називається ось підказує
ж колеги пародист вона називається можна
її скачати
туди просто вписати своє ім'я та прізвище та
там наприклад володимир путін привітати
тебе з днем ​​народження що цікаво
програма російська дуже цікавий
момент на це все про тебе звертають
увага програма російська там все
російські зірки там владимир
жиринівський путін пізно собчак ось все
російські зірки та з усіх російських
добавка владимир зеленський владимир
дитячі які жартують буду вийду звідси
розбий ніхто ми так до літа ви просто
кажіть своїми прізвищами пишіть
ставите правильно і наголос вона монтує
вам за 4 секунди ви готовий ролик пишіть
отримайте сьогоднішні технології ми живемо
у вік високих і голубів діджиталізації
на дворі
ну і судного боку я дівиця як тисяча
хочу поделку етапу на андреа андрей
луганський блогерам
тихіше виграєш ти раніше глибоко
сорочок ця риба розумі 1000 c
dos атаки серйозно за грізний
національні вас з'явиться ще й дали
загині хайке буде ростів віджет з
околиці що знаходиться ми ерік воюємо а і
росія травня серйозніша
фібри гнув інформативну провину та водоспад
і нації за зрозуміло забирає